[موسيقى] أجنبية
إذا كنت تعتقد أن ما يقوله لشبونة هو
نصف على الأرض ونصفها على الماء ، فقد قضيت
الكثير من الوقت على اليابسة ، لذا حان الوقت الآن
لاستكشاف نهر تاغوس على هذا
القارب الرائع البرتغال
فخورة بحق ب 500 عام من الإبحار
استكشاف العالم بشكل كبير وراء
شواطئه في عمق المجهول
هنري الملاح نعم وبعد
ذلك ستجد
فاسكو دي جاما هناك ماجلان بيدرو
كابرال
، هذا هو برج بيليم
هو هذه المنطقة من لشبونة ، هذه منطقة ريكاردو
هوديني  فخور برتغالي
بحار بحار منفرد الآن مدرب شركة
نحن هنا في لشبونة والشيء الوحيد
الذي ألاحظه والسبب الذي جعلني أتحدث
إليكم بالطبع هو هذه العلاقة التي
تربط هذا المكان بالبحر
بالمحيطات كيف تريد  صِف ذلك ، نحن
فخورون جدًا بماضينا ، لقد حققنا
شيئًا لا يُصدق منذ أكثر من 500 عام
، ويتم تذكيرنا بهذا
كل يوم على المحيط ، حيث لدينا
هذا النهر الرائع
[الموسيقى]
ولكن ما يجعل لشبونة  بئر
غير مناسب لشبونة هي العاصمة الأوروبية
للمحيطات وهي العاصمة الوحيدة على
المحيط على المحيط الأطلسي ولدينا هذا
الضوء الخاص جدًا الذي يجذب
المصورين والفنانين من جميع
أنحاء العالم العلاقة
مع النهر بالمياه والقرب من
الشواطئ.  موقع رائع ، إنها
مدينة رائعة
، أعتقد دائمًا أن
لشبونة أقل من قيمتها الحقيقية ، لم تُنسى لشبونة ،
لكنها ليست كذلك إذا كنت تحب الفوضى
والحيوية في العواصم الأوروبية الجنوبية الكبرى الأخرى ،
لكن هذا هو عامل
الجذب
الذي أجده في  يتفاجأ
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يأتون من
الخارج إلى لشبونة بما وجدوه في السنوات الخمس الماضية
، وأعتقد أنهم السفراء الحقيقيون
لمدينتنا وبلدنا
كأشخاص من الخارج يتحدثون
بشكل جميل عن البرتغال طعامًا
رائعًا وآمنًا جدًا أناس
رائعون للغاية.  إنه
بلد رائع
[موسيقى] ،
فنحن نقوم به باعتباره النسب إلى
المستكشفين العظماء جيدًا ، يمكنك تتبع ما
أنت تفعل ما فعلوه من
أجل أن أكون قد ولدت في
نفس بلد ماجلان في نفس يوم
ماجلان وقد يقول البعض أننا حتى
متشابهين قليلاً على الرغم من أن
الملف الشخصي هو أه إنه جزء من
نظام قوتي  نحقق ما نحتاجه
لتحقيق ما تشعر به بما يحدث
داخل ريكاردو عندما تأتي تحت هذا
الجسر وترى هذا وأعود إلى
هنا يبدو الأمر كما لو أنني أشعر به
منذ 500 عام مضت ، إنها العودة
إلى حيث بدأ كل شيء
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ، لقد اكتشفنا السائحين الذين عثروا على
البرتغال قبل أن يجد
البرتغاليون البرتغال
، والآن نحن مثل هؤلاء الأشخاص من
البلدان الأخرى يقولون أشياء جيدة
عنا ، ربما يجب أن نأخذهم على
محمل الجد لم نكن جيدين جدًا في  قول
أشياء جيدة عن أنفسنا حتى
يأتي الآخرون ويقولون أشياء جيدة عنا ،
هناك الكثير من الأشياء الجيدة التي يمكن أن
نقولها عن لشبونة ، إنها رائعة سواء
من الماء ومن أعلى
المدينة مع ساعة ذهبية حيث كل
لحظة في الفصل  الفنون وتركني أرغب في
المزيد
[موسيقى]
أجنبية